a plan is 50 centimeters high when first
observer and the first we college nation
it grows ten centimeters okay so with
110 centimeters birth in each succeeding
weaker growth in high is a to set of the
previous week's growth and this is this
is a pattern set up this is kind of art
this is a recursive definition isn't it
right based on what we explode namely
this one you can work out the next week
it'll be eighty percent of that and then
the next week will be at least eighty
percent of the previous week and so on
okay so i can say for week em right
weekend has eighty percent of week n
minus ones alright so there's my
somewhat awkward verbal way of stating
the recursive definition they've handed
me the question if this pattern of
growth continues what will be its
ultimate height okay so when you see the
moment ultimate as in where it's going
to end what does that word ultimate
indicate to you that what kind of
question this is this has to be a
limiting some type question right this
has to be a living cell because no other
kind of some has an ultimate value of
any meaning right for example aP's aps
they can't possibly have a limiting song
right because the terms are just getting
bigger and bigger and being a bigger or
smaller small it's more and more
negative they're never going to go
towards something okay gps and you can
sort into it that we're gonna can't keep
using up because if the eighty percent
is a common ratio right gps can have a
limiting some in particular conditions
and we're going to dig into medicine so
i just written down the fact now how I
solve the question really depends on how
i phrase the question right so to help
you think about this
do you notice I've got the first week of
growth and then I've got me to and we
three and we forum with five and then i
have this 50 centimeters okay this 50
center is now if I'm trying to form a GP
right then the GP I want do something
like this right that's what it's going
to look like now I already know that for
instance one of the terms is going to be
plus 10 there's that growth in the first
week and another one of the terms is
going to be plus eight is that okay like
that'll be the next one and then the
next one will be plus six point four and
so on right so I've got these numbers
already happening in my head yes okay
now question when is the 50 fit into a
sequence like this where does it fit in
ok now if i say TN minus one that kind
of depends on what n is right so TN
minus one could be any of these terms
but I'm thinking about a specific number
this 50 right I can tell you where it
fits in one scrap book is 50 in here
right is that an AP or a GP like this
sequence attack neither an AP Nora GP is
it because look at the common
differences if you want to pick a peel
and right common difference 40 common
difference to common difference 1.6 it's
not happening ok let's think about a
common ratio well the ratio here is a
fifth and then it's four fifths and then
for Fitz and in for fierce it's not
happening isn't it ok so therefore I
know someone like I know right from the
get-go I can't include 50 in the
sequence right obviously I'll have to
bring it into account later on if I want
to get an accurate answer but it can't
be part of my series because it won't be
an AP where pgp therefore nothing's
going to work so here's how I'm going to
define it let s n equal ok know if I'm
ignoring your starting point right are
the future
okay what would be a meaningful way to
describe SN such as s1 s2 s3 are going
to give me something I can work with any
ticket yeah okay so you're thinking
about terms that's grew it we are going
to get terms in a minute but okay I want
to some right I need some because I'm
going to get an ultimate height so I
need a limit yourself so I'm going to
say SF let it be sorry the total amount
of growth that's what's happening when I
add up this number and this number and
this number right 10 and 8 and 6.4 or
how much it grows each time how much it
gets bigger okay the total length of
birth by the eighth week it's at a
reasonable way to describe this because
I can fit in what I already know in
terms of this definition very very
easily for instance s 1 by definition is
the total amount of growth by the first
week by the first week that's this
number 10 when I add on another week
keeping in mind that is the total amount
of growing right I've got to have the
previous week's growth which is 10 and
then I have another eighty percent of
that number right now i could write that
as eight but to make the GP little
clearer there's no need to evaluate that
ratio i might as well just pop it there
0.8 there's my eighty percent okay with
that okay and then just to establish my
patent on to my third term yup there's
the first week's growth there's the
second week's growth and then here comes
the third week now i'm adding them all
together because i want the total right
it's all there excuse me yeah
20.8 has been oh ok now let's read the
question again it says in each
succeeding week right so for example in
this week right the growth in that week
is eighty percent of the previous week's
growth so this here that 10 x 0.8 oh
that's the previous week's growth but
this is the total all of the week's
growths added up okay so so only this is
the previous week's growth so therefore
this is the current week's growth it's
eighty percent of that just like this is
eighty percent of that okay so far so
good excellent now I could do this in a
quick and messy way but I don't know how
many questions how many marks this
question attract so I'm going to do it
in a full informal way okay the reason I
went 123 is because now I've got three
terms I can see the pattern so I can
make a statement about what kind of
series this is so on the basis of this I
can say this is a GV right what do I
know about this GP it has a first term
of 10 and it has a common ratio of which
is your name now again because I don't
know how it marks on here I'm going to
be as formal as I can you remember that
you said you told me right up here we're
going to need a living some in here
right you can't just pull out a living
some of any GP you can only pull them
out of some which clients and GPS have
them exams
good is that it's that common ratio
right you can say in one of two ways you
can either say it's between sorry
between negative 1 and 1 or you can use
your absolute value notation and you can
say it this way okay I kind of prefer
this place but it doesn't matter they're
the same statement so i can say since
the absolute value art is less than one
and i can make this statement because i
made it i observed it right now it was
this GP has a limiting song okay so you
see if we are are being proper about
this we can't just pull out a living
some of nowhere right you've got to be
able to say why is there a living some
you should justify that that's an
important point 1 to steady the ship it
has earning some ie now that i've stated
why it has a living soul well we know
what our formula further new something's
right it's it's the first term it's a on
1 minus are okay with that so that's 10
/ 0.2 what's the arrow point to as a
fraction that's a fifth so dividing by a
fit is the same as multiplying by 5 so
that's 50 okay so pause for a second
right we've now comes the end of some
working what am I going to do with that
one what does it s represents
it's the total amount of growth right
and you remember that growth had you
artfully nor the 50 that we started with
right because we couldn't fit it in and
preserve the GP okay so now I can
actually answer the question what is the
ultimate height the height will be what
you started with your initial
observation that's going to be 50 plus
however much it ultimately grows and
that's what the meaning some will show
me and there's my on top okay so just
you know importantly i would probably
guess that i'd expect there to be three
nights on this I'd expect free marks on
this if they were really a bit stingy
and T to get away with being a bit brief
the first buck is going to be for
demonstrating this see what you've got a
you've got to climb with a series but
demonstrates what's going on here okay
I'm none of this by the way nothin this
is likely to attract marks in itself ok
but what we'll do is we'll help you nail
this part which does okay and i can tell
you really really confidently a lot of
students who skip here and there just
this one dive in okay they've got a
reasonable success rate but if they
screw this up they screw it up
completely and they've got no recourse
to go back and say but why am I wrong
well I am I getting some number which
doesn't make sense or what I get a
number that's wrong but I did it I don't
even know what's wrong because I've no
choice analyzing so mark would be here
another one would be there for
identifying what's going on and then the
last mark would be in combining these
two steps okay if you ended here you
probably would not get anything without
saying this but at the same time you
know if you get this but you didn't show
you where it came from that also
wouldn't be sufficient because you want
to tell me where that will need some
factors in